all right so after my sort of bum slash
nostalgia critic review uh you might be
wondering what my real thoughts are on
transformers 4 or if that even was my
real thoughts and it kind of is honestly
um it's uh it's funny because I think
this is like I I should first of all why
isn't Rob here um I've literally out of
principle he decided not to see it he
decided to forego it sibling rivalry
said I know it's going to be bad I've
learned my lesson I'm not seeing these
um and thankfully he's in position where
he can do that you know I this is a big
thing anything that's like a big
phenomenon in terms of like movies and
yeah I mean especially movies I mean I
kind of got a cover I mean it is my job
even if it's bad how my wife is making
fun of bad movies
um but yeah so we got soso he didn't go
see it I know I wasn't gonna like it but
I didn't know it was gonna be this auto
pilot
I mean it's like we got new Transformers
we got new main characters we got rid of
which wiki you know like he's gone I saw
that well okay me it was will be better
you know he was getting pretty annoying
his parents were ungodly annoying and
you know to go over the other films real
fast I mean it I liked the first film
even though I acknowledge it's really
stupid
um but I thought it was fun I thought
was entertaining I thought at the time
we never really saw action like that
from giant robots punching themselves I
mean it really was sort of like a
teenage a badass Saturday morning
cartoon really and that's I mean granted
the original transformers is for
eight-year-olds I was only there to sell
products but it was cool and there was
kind of this weight to introducing the
Transformers and building them up and it
but he never took itself too seriously
and I like the if I as someone doesn't
like it I'm not gonna defend it as one
of our great I mean I know it's stupid
but but I really liked it um and then
you got I just gotta say the second
third one together cuz they're the exact
same movie
they're the exact same movie is the
first one nothing was different about
them uh and it's a shame because when I
saw the first film I was actually
thinking maybe Michael Bay is the guy to
direct these innocence because they're
they still speak to a wide audience but
they still give us kind of what we're
looking for they gave us Optimus Prime
he has the voice you know they didn't
make up new Transformers or whatever I
mean there's still our transformers um
and I start like the first one because
there's almost a satire of his style
like there is people kind of laughing
and kya cheering at some point and
there's okay there's actually a few
moments in the sequels where I felt they
got it right with that like in a LAN se
was three uh with the moon landing and
they're like it's one small step for man
one giant leap for mankind cut
transmission okay let's go for why we're
really hearing it's to give a
transformer that bullshit is wonderful
and this film starts off similar it
didn't you know that it wasn't a meteor
it wasn't any of that that destroyed the
dinosaurs it was transformers didn't you
know that that nonsense is wonderful and
I wanted more of that so funny how
that's two movies that row now that
started off with that silliness I really
thought well maybe maybe this will be
okay like maybe this will be just so
friggin out there it's silly and stupid
that I'll be able to enjoy but it it
just goes to the exact same thing and
you got Mark Wahlberg as Shia LaBeouf
and his daughter in this movie who's you
know playing Megan Fox um some surfer
dude who's like you know since Michael
Bay real I know I can't make fun of
black people now I might as well just
make fun of white people up this movie
is kind of races against white people
although you could argue that uh Lobos
parents in the movie work at erases to
white people nobody looks good in a
transformer movie it's not Pro any race
gender anything um so anyone that says
they're racist you're right but it's
races against everybody everyone looks
awful um so yeah so he's
he's a bit better than Shia LaBeouf but
he's still written as nothing he's he's
the WiDi inventor who just wants to make
something and provide but he's getting a
little too far but he just knows if he
believes and and trusts a little harder
and stuff but he's an overprotective dad
and the daughter who's like a fucking
knockout of course you can't have an
attractive woman at Michael Bay film
right
unattractive anybody really um you know
of course you know she's he don't you go
dating boy of course she has a boyfriend
of course he's you know a friggin
knockout and of course he has the cool
car he's so and then the girl K the
government in this oh man I mean this is
like bad 80s comedy climax this is
they're all in black cars they all have
the black trench coats they have the
black shades which like I said if they
were if the rest of the movie was kind
of like that is strange away I win mine
but it's trying to be really intently no
no these these really are the bad guys
man these really are and it's and it's
so bad Kelsey Grammer leads them and
he's sometimes he's kind of fun and how
over-the-top he is but if not enough and
I think I said the review uh the NC
review Optimus Prime is a fuckin psycho
and I guess you'd understand cuz like
now mankind just wants to destroy
transformers because Michael Bay needs
his slo-mo bullshit of somebody
suffering and you know somebody's
shaking their head saying what was it
for is is it worth it just so they can
get back up and say yes and it doesn't
matter what it is it doesn't matter it
makes not a lick of sense whatsoever it
just needs somebody to be down in slow
motion shaking their head saying my god
is it worth it and someone triumphantly
getting up saying yes nothing else
needed that is the formula um so they
find that the Transformers aren't hiding
now because the big bad government wants
to take him down um there's a new enemy
I forget what he's called but he kind of
wants to collect Optimus Prime for like
his collection kind of um again which
would be fine but no it's
curious huh and and then it's like so
they're trying outrun these guys and the
government while partaking in not one
funny joke in the whole thing I was
actually amazed that there wasn't one
laugh in the whole thing I mean like two
and three as bad as they are it's like
at least giggled maybe twice I mean this
didn't have a laugh it was amazing um so
try think about us okay so they're
they're just action scenes I mean like
none of them connect to anything I mean
I get it so you think two and three are
bad for not connecting anything it's
like this they get 10 minutes longer
each film I there's literally scene
where Stanley Tucci who's that - not the
badness um but he's a guy and he's
trying to he's owning this company and
he's he's got this big bad bomb the seed
or whatever and he's just trying to
outrun these guys and he's in an
elevator and we just should they just
show him waiting on the elevator and
kind of talking and then some guys come
in and then his assistant kicks their
ass and then he goes up on the elevator
and it was like five six minutes
dedicated to it's like what was the
point of that you could have just cut
that there was and then the guy in the
elevator also gets out and fights it and
so we have no idea who that guy is or
what his story is or it just fights and
yeah it's Megatron's back it like in the
novels halfway or the last third cuz
they had like you know eight climaxes
you know the whole film is one long
climax and you know but he barely does
anything as a little fight I think in
the middle and then he just as our hero
go there you go there and it's like oh
wait other guy's a bad guy yeah maybe I
should go over here and then it's when
it's all said day is like oh they're
certain over I'll see you in
transformers 5 which is like fuck cuz
it's you know it's worth okay it's one
thing if you saw the opening night which
I didn't um and you see it and you just
server hoping you know yeah well we'll
see how this does and everything but
knowing it already made a hundred
million at the box office over the
weekend and when you hear that line you
just like yep are gonna do it and I'm
gonna have to see
mark so I and I'm trying everything out
there doctors brian goes up into space
why are there no fucking battles in
space okay the climax in this movie all
twelve or twenty of them is in it's not
even in a new city it's in Chicago
that's climax one and then it goes to I
think Hong Kong that's like okay it's a
little different but come on guys you
got mountains you got space you got
other planets our plants you can and our
cool spaceship so you can design at
least a little differently you know not
just metal on metal you know not just
stuff that looks like transformers porn
and that's it you know just looks like a
bunch of transformers you know compacted
together while making out that's the
ship that's the design of the whole
movie and it just gave me nothing and it
was so long and it was so boring and the
fight thing is unlike the annoyance
meter like two or three is probably
worst but by the fact that so many years
have gone by since the first film and
just nothing has changed they are giving
us the exact same bullshit I mean stuff
that you know early 90s you know what
sort of say okay is this gang a little
old I mean it's and they just keep
giving it to us so I don't know man it's
it that the whole that whole bit I went
on as the emcee and everything I mean
really was just playing for my mind um I
really did just want to go to some of
those people and just feeling isn't
there anything better you can do with
your life right now isn't this what is
this giving you what could this possibly
give you um and I don't know I like I
say I'm very much of the philosophy that
you can like what you like and don't let
anyone tell you what not to like but I
mean it's I don't know what is it
honestly doing now that is of any
substance I mean even the first one
didn't have much substance but it was
still you know it was still a little
different and it still gave us something
on a grand scale and this is just the
exact same scale
it's gone down a bit the Transformers I
think look awful I mean like I'm not
talking about the designs I mean I'll at
least give it that like at least I could
tell some of them apart like oh that's
samurai transformer that's Walter from
Big Lebowski transformer you know at
least I could tell them apart but yeah
what is it doing that you're like yeah
I'm glad I saw that that gave me
something that the other films didn't
give me even the fucking dinosaur it's
like I'll lean for the dinosaurs I want
see some robot dinosaur action Optimus
Prime riding a dinosaur idea come on
it's let's go and they're only in it for
a few minutes at the end I had that
whole build up in the opening with like
you know them turning the dinosaurs into
these robots or whatever whatever they
were doing and it's like oh this is
gonna be so much fun but it's just it's
shaky cam its slow-mo of people spinning
Oh
they even repeat on the highway the
highway chase that has to be in all of
them uh there's even one scene where
like they're driving and they the
Transformers there the cars whatever and
then they trip or they fall out and they
turn to robots and the people that were
inside are flying what do they do you
saw this they grab them and they put
them back inside race we're begging the
cars it's like the exact same fucking
thing he said this time they go through
a truck and two other people scream what
is that adding um I said it really
pissed me Elise me all cuz I am just so
dime so tired and I have to go people
who saw this movie if you're not gonna
think for yourselves at least think for
us and we think that we have to go see
this stuff you have a choice we don't um
but yeah I I can't figure it um and I'm
not saying that anyone I want to see
this film you know it is stupid or
whatever I just I clearly don't
understand it I just don't grasp it at
all um and yeah I mean it's I don't even
know if it can be expressed pop is to
say but if it can be explained to me you
know but I because I just get the
feeling it's gonna be like you know just
go put
awesome explosions and faithing and it's
like just I don't know it isn't there is
there something else is there something
just clearly really fun and cool that
I'm missing I just can't believe how
boring Michael Bay has made a action
he's just made it so boring and but not
me that is a good thing and maybe really
is um because now I I really mean what I
say when I said this year is answered
them pretty good for summer films and
last year was wonderful for summer films
um it was a very female dominated uh
last year to which I i think is probably
better because it's like you know yeah
you'll have the action and stuff but
they'll talk they'll actually talk about
stuff and it's like hey remember caring
it's like that they'll kind of do that
here um so yeah I don't know what it is
um about it and I don't think it's gonna
bring down cinema I really think this
sort of style of filmmaking and
everything I think it's kind of like not
that's on its way out or anything
because clearly this made a lot of money
but I think there's just more people are
seeing value in you know clever you know
and and funny and smart you know along
with the action you know lego movie was
a very smart movie who the hell have
thought that you know but but it was and
was extremely clever um and animated
films now are so much more interesting
than they were before so I still think
we're getting a lot of good films really
um I grew up in the dark age of from
like Batman and Robin to Godzilla you
know that that dark three or four years
um but yeah I I guess there's always
gonna be an audience for just you know
dumb explosions and with nothing else at
it I mean it's just there's like there's
always going to be an audience for
Twilight you know or terrible romances I
mean it's just it it's playing to the
most primal of humans you know I'm just
saying wouldn't you wouldn't you choose
to evolve
I mean it's like III know we're born
this way and we're animals and stuff but
but wouldn't you choose to be to have
more given to you um you know I can't
remember this made in the review at all
but I was saying it's like eating fast
food and I eat fast food sometimes too
but the reason we don't eat much better
food or healthier food whatever usually
I mean like healthy food that actually
tastes good is because it costs more and
it junk food is is cheap if a food is
cheap and fast and all that stuff
movies they cost the exact same why not
why not see something that's gonna
challenge you why not see something
that's gonna add something and not take
away this just took away two two and a
half I could do it I have like two hours
45 minutes something like that out of my
life you know so I don't know it's in a
strange way it pissed me off more even
though I know it's not technically the
worst but it's just frustrating it's
like watching a drug addict who will
never learn or an alcohol like you know
it's I'm not talking about that people
who go see us I'm just about the films
in general it's like oh come on it's
like cuz I think Michael Bay has to have
some he made the first one and he knows
the potential of marketing and making
something fun but you know just
challenge yourself guy I mean if not for
you know the movie-going public just
just challenge yourself you know do
something different you know every
reestablishes re-create yourself i mean
it you got the money you're pretty much
said why not why not do something
different you know well why not try
something really out there and goofy and
fun that's not transformers I mean
that's cuz it's not goofy and fun
anymore it's you just press rewind you
got millions of dollars thrown at you
just to push the reline button you know
and except you didn't just push the
button you had people work really hard
to create these giant special effects to
create the exact same things we saw
they're just given different names or
slightly different designs and I don't
know throw a dinosaur in the last 10
you know that's and and we're falling
for it so I don't know um this is really
bitter I'm sorry it it is what I think
and if you like it I don't get it
um but I I don't know if I want to maybe
I do just just so I can understand more
but yeah I don't get it man
um arrows gonna have their own taste and
this just clearly isn't mine so uh yeah
that's I think you can get it just from
my thoughts on it and what you probably
think so guys uh I will see you later
take care